can you please confirm with my screen is
visible
yes the screen is visible
thank you
all right I can see that few
participants have joined uh we'll be
starting with the webinar in just few
more minutes
and meanwhile we are waiting uh it would
be great if the participants can
introduce themselves in the chat box you
can let me know about your education
background and research interest
all right so without further delay let's
start with today's webinar so hello
everyone very warm greeting to one and
all my name is
and I would like to welcome you all for
the webinar on women Technologic
bioinformatics and data science research
fellowship program
the research fellowship program has been
designed to help young researchers and
students take advantage of the buying
magic resources for the analysis of
complex Lifeline data and become
well-worked in buy-informatics research
fellows participate in cutting-edge
client marriage research led by expert
Mentor from Academia and Industry the
fellowship program will offer a
combination of online resources and
mental guidance to prepare you and help
you complete a buying thematic project
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program we are us-based mind management
company who is working with multiple
academic and Commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more active
and as part of our mission our team is
working with local and Regional
coordinators that are helping to find
local program Logistics and adapting
them to the needs of students and
researchers around the world and this
training has been completed by over 24
000 participants from 187 countries in
over 300 workshops in six different
specialization tracks that includes
oncology infectious diseases prediction
medicine neuroscience and data science
for biomedical data
and as a part of the training program
you will have access to the omic
resources which takes a combination of
training modules data analysis curated
data set and interactive sessions with
mentors to give the students a clear
path of the Bloom's taxonomy group
and this also comes with an access to
the almost or the courses which includes
courses on by informatics Precision
medicine multi-onic including economics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
data time that includes blind marriage
youth are in Python SLS cheminformatics
and example project of different fields
which you could learn from and replicate
for your research
the almost logic platform also gives
options for analyzing a given data type
and these data sets in Associated
Publications can be used in several ways
first you can learn bioinformatics
without any coding at all for those
interested in opting the non-code
pathway they will be given directions to
access the T by info platform for
bioinformatic processing and Analysis of
data the platform includes demo
pipelines as well as data management and
Analysis Cloud infrastructure to run the
binary pipeline and different stages of
analysis are performed in different
sections on this multiromics platform
for those interested in learning to
analyze data through coding we provide
the omnic storage code playground which
will help you develop coding skills
while learning popular packages in our
programming and python to visualize
annotate and analyze complex patterns in
biological data
so now to view the various courses and
exam projects or student projects you
need to per sign up on the owner
strategy player on Portal
so for that let me walk you through on
how you can sign up
so here is the link for signing up and
pasting it in the chat box to the
participants
please visit the link and I'll walk you
through how you can
so when you visit the link you have the
option to create an account so those
participants who have not created an
account on the quota yet so then please
click on the create an account option
that you'll see here and once you click
on this you can enter your name provide
an email ID and password and you can
or you can also sign up using any of
your social media handles this could be
your Google Facebook account Apple
account GitHub account or even Twitter
and for those participants who already
have an existing account on the portal
you can simply click on the login now
option that you see here and simply
enter the existing email ID and password
and click on find
so with that I'll pause for a couple of
seconds for the participants to sign up
and one sign up please put a yes in the
chat box so that I know I can proceed
ahead
and if you already have a account on the
port and then please put a done in the
chat box as well
[Music]
all right uh Walter a variable to sign
up or do you have any queries on signing
up if so I'll be happy to explain once
more
and along the way if you are facing any
technical issues while signing up you
can let us know as well and our team is
here they will be happy to look into it
and get it resolved
all right so without further a delay I'm
just going to click on sign in but
please let me know in the chat once you
have signed up I'll be monitoring the
chat as well side by side
so since I already have an account on
the portal I'm just going to click on
sign in
so once you sign in you will be able to
see the various uh courses
um that are there on the portal so once
you install down below you will see a
search bar that says looking for a
specific course so here after you sign
up you can enter a keyword that you're
interested to learn more about so let's
say you are interested in transcript
comic then you can enter the keyword
performing and that will show you the
various courses and example projects
that make use of the concept on
transport so as you can see there are
several courses on transatronics Oneness
transport comics and one is on single
cell transfer comics and then
transatronics using our programming and
Python Programming and several example
projects such as post response to
malaria infection and
several other example projects that you
can take a look at at your own
page so this is what you can see under
the courses tab so for now it is
important that you have to set up your
account for that you can simply click on
the blue bar that will be welcome back
with your email ID
the ones you click here it will take you
to your account settings so it is very
important that you have a completed
profile on the portal to complete your
profile you can simply click on the icon
that says profile and this will enable
you to edit the features on the button
that is make sure that your name is in
proper capitalization and that you add a
brief power about your thing that that
will consist of your education
background and research interest and add
a profile image for yourself as well and
also link your social media and the port
so once you update your profile on the
portal it will show 100 complete
also take a look at the various tabs
that are there on the bottom so for
instance under the activity tab the
mentor of the program and the community
manager will be tracking your learning
program under the courses tab you will
be able to see the various courses and
example projects that you are currently
taking
under the project stack once you
complete a project as a part of the
program and publish it on our portal
that will be displayed under the project
tab under the program tab once you
enrolled for the research fellowship
program that will be displayed under the
program Tab and finally after the
completion of your coursework with the
required assignments and courses the
certificates will appear under the
certificates
so that was all about uh setting up your
profile and the various tabs that you
see here and another important tab that
I want to show you is the projects tab
here
once you click on this you will be able
to see the various student projects that
have been carried out as a part of the
research fellowship program and these
projects topics range from oncology
infectious diseases Precision medicine
machine learning neuroscience and so on
so the participants can have a look at
all of these student projects that are
there on the portal and for today's
webinar we are joined by one of our
research fellows Michael who will be
presenting her research project that has
been carried out on as I moved so with
that I'll pass on the stage to Michaela
the state is soldiers
hi everyone hi srigorian
yes hello Michaela
uh is it possible for you to present my
slides from your side please
let me take a look at it
sure
foreign
visible
yes it is thank you so much
okay so hi good afternoon everyone good
evening in your respective time zones my
name is Michaela Chetty and I have been
working on transcriptomic analysis of
human beta amyloid in the model organism
which isn't a matter of the C elegans
so um let me that is my project topic
that I have worked on
um with
omics logic
but before I go on to that let me just
introduce myself and say a bit about
myself my name is Michaela Chetty I have
completed my BSC in biotechnology and my
MSC and zoology after that I took a gap
year I worked on some research projects
and as you all know covert hit
um yes
so that's when I started developing more
um computer skills
I am currently doing research at an
institutes and I also work on C elegans
but in the wet lab so C elegans has been
one of my um favorite organisms
because of its close similarity and it's
um you know evolutionary uh
companionship that it had with humans
around 600 million years ago
and that's why they are good to work
with the other very important factor to
take note and into consideration is that
when we extract human samples
they might not always be in the best
condition possible
for example if we're talking about
neurodegeneration then um extracting
brain samples or you know DNA or
um proteins from the brain itself it
needs to be maintained in the proper
sterile environment in the proper
temperature in the proper um you know
atmosphere that is suitable for that
sample whereas if you're using a model
organism
um
I could say that research is a little
bit more um friendlier or easier if I
could put it that way
which the Elegance is grown in a body 22
degrees on an agar plate so not much
stress and fast is over there my
interest lies in neurodegeneration
primarily and Alzheimer's disease I have
been Affiliated or you know attracted
towards Alzheimer's disease for I would
say the past 10 years
uh it's a bit of a personal reason but
it led into a scientific affiliation
after I started my bachelor degree
and
throw neurodegeneration I have
planned or you know intend intended to
further my career and I came across
omics logic
uh there's research fellowships online
and I thought wow this is a great
opportunity for me to you know get on
some Hands-On skills and it's definitely
going to help develop my profile and I'm
going to learn new skills that I can add
to my CV I can use the skills to further
analyze more data and while analyzing
more data you get to know more of the
proteins or more of the gene sequences
or more of the
um
comparative analysis that can be done
so that's a bit about me and
I have started with the omics logic
portal
um by doing a few of the basic courses
because I am not originally from a
biotechnology I mean a bioinformatics
background so I am from a biotechnology
background we did have the course but it
was a subject
so I started with introduction to
bioinformatics I further did the bytes
and molecules cost that is available on
their online website
and I further did the transcriptomic
course and I developed more skills and
interest and questions from you know
these three main branches of courses on
the omics logic portal
so without further Ado I will continue
on to talking about my project that I
have done
so on the screen I have listed
um you know my objectives of the project
that I set out to do and my data was
available online through ncbi and
um I had taken these three objectives
based on the data and like I said before
my filtering method or my um choice of
data was done by my uh interests so my
interest is neurodegeneration and C
elegans so when I had put this into a
Geo online I had found that they had
only given me around 7 or 11
data samples and
um obviously I put the CL against filter
and that's how I got such a smaller
number of data available online and
this one the status that had attracted
me a little bit more than the rest
because of its a vast number of samples
and they had used
um a c elegant strain that represents
amyloid beta deterioration or
neurodegeneration so that was really
interesting for me to see the
computational biology aspect of it
because we know that the transgenic C
elegans is available but you know when
you
get its data it's a different thing
because you can further conclude more
results
that is how I chose my data and the
objectives that I have chosen are listed
on the screen so
my first objective was to see the
changes in human beta amyloid peptide
and gene expression
and the second objective was to identify
the pathways that were taken or
triggered by amyloid beta toxicity over
time there were different time points
and the third objective
um
one of the you know prominent ones I
would say or important because that
gives it its human in significance was
to see the orthologous biological
functions in humans
so
as we all know about neurodegenerative
diseases
they are coming to be quite common these
days I would say not necessarily a good
thing because
um it leads to a downfall on one's life
and
um that one being normally an elderly
person generally above 50 years of age
so
in the brain of a person who is
diagnosed with Alzheimer's disease
there is a specific protein called beta
amyloid protein which is involved in
Alzheimer's
um I must say
that
um
the beta amyloid
protein
is
one of the um accumulans or you know it
has been said that it when excessive
accumulation
of amyloid beta it causes Alzheimer's
and um that's why there is studies done
on the protein called beta amyloid or
amloid beta it's pretty much
interchangeable
uh based on your lab or your location
different people use different
um first words for them
so the Beta Android protein which is
involved in Alzheimer's um it has
different molecular forms that it takes
place between neurons as you can see in
the picture it's uh on the end of the
part of the neuron
so it is formed by
it is formed by a larger protein which
is broken down and the larger protein is
called the Android precursor protein
this is normally
um the beta amyloid 1 to 42. as it's
commonly known and it is toxic what
happens is that the proteins Clump
together
when they Clump together they form
plaques
and these plaques collect between the
neurons
and they do not allow the
cell to function appropriately of
function in its rightful manner
so that is the um purpose of
studying beta amyloids
and uh just on a side note the um Tau
neurofability Tangles it's also known as
hypophosphorylated Tau tangles
the the chemical structure of it so it's
inside the neurons
so healthy neurons are supported by
internal structures known as
microtubules and these microtubules are
very important in guiding nutrients and
molecules from cell bodies to axon to
dendrites
but when Tau Tangles are not
um in proper form or they are sticking
to other Tau molecules they form threads
and these threads eventually join
together to form Tangles inside the
neurons
what happens is that these Tau Tangles
or hypophosphorylated cow Tangles they
block the neurons transport system and
in you can say long-term effect this
harms the synaptic communication between
neurons
so um this is just a bit about the
molecular and basic
um molecular and biochemical aspect of
amyloid beta and Tau
um Tangles that happens
and um what happens is that in some
cases or in most cases the the diet the
dead and the dying nerve cells because
they're not getting proper nutrients
they end up getting twisted and Tangled
between each other and beta amyloid the
chemical form of beta amyloid gets
sticky and when it gets sticky they
group together
because of sticky ends when they stick
together they form plaques and
um you know it blocks the signal
synapses
ideally
not good
um for the human or you know for anybody
because that's the basis of
neurodegeneration and um you can say
it's an aiding factor to
neurodegeneration there are additional
factors such as genetic and
environmental but this is one of the
most prominent ones and literature shows
thus quite evidently
so going on to my project
um
we had taken a sample or the data sets
that is available online
and I have listed the pmid over here on
the screen in the data set there were
three strains of C elegans
so
um each stream
contained a different
um
a different uh like you know I could say
a physical feature or the biochemical
feature so in one strain cl4176 this had
the human amyloid beta in worm strain
cl2337 thus carried the protein
expression or neurodegeneration of
amyloid beta expression so this had
um you know the amyloid beta plugs
basically what is trying to say add worm
strain cl2179 this was used as a
negative control to evaluate and see the
results that we were getting you know as
a comparison method
um yeah
so why do many Labs use C elegans
apart from it being a model organism
C elegans is um
back you know many years ago like I
mentioned before 600 million years ago
there was an evolutionary theory split
that took place they had a common
ancestor with humans and the common
ancestor was known as a botanic of a
tailoring ancestor
so the split took place and that's how
um the nematode C elegans commonly known
as a worm looks a little bit different
okay not a little bit quite different to
a human
but you should know that they have a
minimum of 60 genes that are homologous
so that's quite a large number to
um note down
despite the physical or phenotypic
differences that have been noted so C
elegans are hermaphrodite which means
that they have two sexes in them they
have uh poem and oocytes first this poem
is produced and then the usai the USA
passes into the spermatateca and then
it's fertilized that's how fertilization
takes place in a hermaphrodite
they grow and multiply in large numbers
so in a laboratory one does not have a
shortage of sample or shortage of
organism that is not very common in a c
elegant laboratory it is grown on a MGM
agar plate or a petri dish as you can
see on the bottom left on the screen
there is an image of a petri dish so
liquid media is made and allowed to
solidify and they are grown on the media
they have a very fast life cycle
um it usually takes around 24 hours to
get gravity gravid worms again which is
quite
um a good
time span for you know experiments they
do allow for long-term cryopreservation
which means that you are allowed to
freeze them if in case covert happens
again then you know our samples will
always be safe and storage securely
going on to
um the expert the Practical experience
that I gained through omics logic I um
I extracted the data from my um pmid
that I have listed above and
um I filtered it and sorted it out in
terms of time frame I then
um
perform the t-test
so the t-test is essentially quite
important I would say in because in a
statistical means it's a measure of
probability that you can obtain your
results from so you can see the
difference between groups in my case I
had different time groups I had
different time frames time frame for a
12 16 and this was done so
um
ideally lower the P value the more
confident you can be that you know your
observed effect is real and this is in
terms of when you are um using grouped
data which in my case it was
and after that I did the p-adjusted
value
which gave me a more statistical data
that I could use to
um
filter out and see my data I then um
after the p-adjusted value I then
ordered it in terms of number wise so I
could see which was
um going to be upregulated and which was
going to be down regulated
which gave me a good idea and um
you know so when you get your P value
you can see the numbers some of them
come in negatives and some of them come
in positives
and
yeah so
just give me one minute I'm
I think the internet is
hello can you hear me
we can hear you
okay okay sure okay so
after doing the changes and then we we
did the p-value sorted and after that we
did the p-adjusted and after that the
log Fortune so this was pretty much the
um process of and the method that was
taking place
the differential gene expression
analysis was um
significant because we use 95 of
confidence which means that we use 0.05
and this gave us a good
um
evaluation for our data mine in my case
the data set of time frame 16 was very
significant I
um used this data to get a Venn diagram
which is
um like a comparison graph or you know a
chart that you can say where I've put
all my data into and time Point 16 was
most significant in the sense that it
had more number of values that needed to
be considered
so after doing this I further went on to
the gene enrichment analysis
which there are many sites available for
the model organism C elegans
so I used one cats
to get my data
and I used another website called author
list so author list has quite a number I
mean more than 7000 protein coding genes
of C elegans itself
and it gives us the human ortholog
to that specific
um
you know protein so on the screen right
now you can see the data that was
resulted from upregulation and this was
done through worm cats like I mentioned
one catches the online websites that
anyone can access there's no
restrictions yeah so
um
my daughter received that I I mean the
data that I got was quite
um I would say
or normal or I would say me knowing
about neurology generation it was a
little bit good because microtubules are
very common in neurodegeneration
signaling phosphatase or transmembrane
proteins collagen these are all very
common things that take place in a
neurodegenerative organism or human but
to my surprise there was a very um
uncommon or you know two uncommon things
I would say and they were amongst the
top
four so I think anything in the top five
is very significant and relevant in any
data sets so number one being regulated
by multiple stresses
and when I further went to evaluate
those in a biological manner then I saw
which genes specifically it was mostly
the Daft Gene staff 2 daf 12-16 that
were regulating multiple stresses and
what type of stress regulation did they
cause
other
um
surprise if I would call it is Major
sperm protein and I would normally not
assume major sperm protein to be in the
neurons
but I think
um
you know major sperm protein could have
some kind of immune response
significance or symbolization or
structural similarity and hence because
of you know the protein fold and the
immunoglobin structures there might be
some kind of
similarity in that and that's why I
think computational biology is very
important because it shows us a
different aspect or it gives us a
different pathway that we can take to
explore what we already know or what we
might not know for that matter for
example
um
and there has been studies done on mice
and the you know immunological effect in
neurodegeneration so there might be not
any studies down on humans but because
of you know bioinformatics and
computational biology we can use this
data and translate it into medicine or
into wet lab where we can further you
know develop or ascertain the cause or
the treatment plan for neurodegenerative
diseases
so on the next slide I have just
elaborated a little bit about
microtubules
for those of you who are new to the
neurogen degeneration field
um microtubules are very important and
they are there in the structural Network
so
um they are like I mentioned in the
beginning about the child Tangles so it
belongs to a tiny super family and there
was a specific ortholog of human
ttbk5 that was very significant in my
readings
thus I have mentioned here as well so it
can be taken down you know into further
analysis but I mean we first first
needed to process the data to get those
kind of outputs
uh another one that was significant on
the next slide was
the transmembrane protein which is also
very
um you know crucial for cell membrane
because in neurodegeneration that's what
deteriorates a lot faster like you know
app Android precursor protein and
hypophosphorylated child protein
so these Tau
um and amyloids they were enriched or
you know affecting the dopamine neurons
and in any other musculature and nervous
structures that were there
but it can also be further studied
um I feel in science there is no dead
end
last but not least my most prominent one
I would say is Major sperm protein
and this definitely needs to be examined
further
but we have seen and very a lot of
number of genes have come out of the
major sperm protein family so
this is something that needs more
studying maybe it's immunological
structure is similar or you know uh
something to do with the immune response
cells
it can be related to
um
anything you know in relation to that
and that will give us a better idea
so overall this is a bit a basic idea
about my project that I have done in
neurodegenerative diseases
and I am further working to put this
together in an informed manner for a
publication and if given the chance then
I would you know definitely take up the
MSP at further studying levels or you
know any of my other significant
readings such as the deaf Gene that have
been seen in stress regulated
um
the the first bracket of multiple
stresses so there were a lot of daf 2
Dev 12 deaf 16. so this can be further
studied in terms of lifespan aging and
longitude
but as of now I am working towards a
publication and that is the direction
that I am going in and I definitely
learned a lot through the project
and thank you for having a wonderful
team that supported me
thank you so much Michaela for that
wonderful presentation and uh before we
wrap up the presentation I just have one
quick ready for you so what advice do
you have for those uh students who um
are want to
um get involved in research but they do
not know how to get started what advice
do you have for today
um
I would tell you to identify firstly
what you know suits you as a biologist
myself
um are you a wet lab person are you a
dry lab person okay so by wet lab and
dry lab I mean dry lab being the
computer staff RNA sequencing
um PCR uh data transcriptomic analysis
molecular docking cam informatics
um that's the dry lab stuff
if you are a wet lab person
that means you enjoy being in the lab
working for long hours very long hours
um you know micro prepared samples
assays proteins
um fluorescent spectrophotometer Mass
Spec that kind of stuff is wet lab
but at the same time while you are
identifying your Niche or your
um your category of what is for you I
would advise you to gain some skills and
techniques through online methods be it
learning a program language are or
python or if you're interested in
proteins go for molecular docking if you
are interested in genes there's genomic
biotechnology if you're interested in
transcriptomics this RNA these micro
array data there's RNA sequencing single
cell and
um because the wet lab and the dry lab
I believe you know I believe as Michaela
they work hand in hand
so you can always count on one another
to
um you know double check or to verify or
to add to your readings or your findings
so for somebody who's new
I will tell you to read a lot to explore
your options to gain skills and to
definitely not
to continue learning you know don't stop
um you find your Niche whether it's DNA
or proteins or you know Mass Spec
metabolites metabolomics ligands
um
there is so much of things and a lot of
this can be done online you know in the
dry lab as well
so in the meantime if you're not getting
any opportunities
um or if you're you know still shooting
your shot trying to send out
applications just everybody has a laptop
these days it's very common so just try
to work on a project online or you know
through online means or dry lab stuff is
what I'm trying to say in the meantime
of you getting your wet lab project
going
but um I believe that they work hand in
hand and that's something that I strive
to do for my further projects
perfect thank you so much for that
respond and uh one final query I see
that you have enrolled for another
program on camera do you plan on
continuing in the same field you think
I'm informatical is it a completely
different
corporate
um so um my passion is neurodegeneration
and I will be honest to say that I'm
staying in neurodegeneration but um I
love proteins and they fold in very
meticulous and fancy ways that I need to
know more about hence my um enrollment
Falls and other programs
and that was a really wonderful
presentation and we look forward to
seeing more about you from uh in the
upcoming day about your research
publication
thank you
and with that now I'd like to pass on
the stage to one of my colleagues
analika who will be explaining more
about the research fellowship program
and the various special ideas
thank you so much
such a wonderful presentation
and I would like to discuss about the
program structure outcomes of the
program and also I'll take up your
queries and listen to
um your questions and answer them
and before I do that I want to know in
the chat box who is our audience so I
just wanted to know uh if you all are
students graduate or post graduate
students or PhD Scholars or researchers
from bioinformatics field or
non-bioinformatics field
please put in the chat
yes susma we have recorded this
please let me know in the chat what is
your background and what is your
research entrance so that we could have
this interaction
uh based on feel that you come from
I'll be arranging for responses and
meanwhile I'll just begin ahead so we
have been discussing about this research
Fellowship training that has been
designed to help young researchers and
students take advantage of
bioinformatics resources for the
analysis of complex life science data
and become well versed in bioinformatics
the research fellows generally
participate in this cutting-edge
bioinformatics research projects that
are led by expert mentors and the
fellowship program offers a combination
of the online resources that I want to
show you today and the mental guidance
that prepares you and helps you complete
a high quality computational research
project that could be either submitted
as a dissertation work in your college
or it could also be published as you are
a part of your thesis
we have been discussing a lot about
bioinformatics data science different
types of Big Data being generated we
know that this field is constantly
growing and developing new tech and
software to improve processing time and
Power the data sets are generally
analyzed that are analyzed are very
large undertake immense amounts of
computing power and memory that many
personal computers do not generally have
also despite being publicly available
the data is so complex to access and
also coding knowledge is usually
required to do so similarly the analysis
pipelines and the programs they require
coding knowledge that many biologists do
not have
and in a university setting the students
they generally have the opportunity to
just learn the background information of
Designing and implementing a research
project but they do not receive the
Practical hands-on experience that I
should say with the full workflow due to
the limitations that I just mentioned
previously similarly faculty also face
challenges with being able to cover a
diverse range of topics if they are
specialized in a certain area
let's say if they are in familiar with
the new tech in general or for example a
professor whose research focuses on
oncogene expression might not know much
about metagenomics of seawater or
neurosciences as you can I mention so
to dwell with this specific uh issues
that we come up with are General
academics uh with regards to the
computational requirements that are
required to work with big data we have
this research fellowship program where
we offer resources that you can utilize
to get yourself uh
up with the skill set that is required
to work with these different types of
data and also you have a platform where
you where you could actually analyze
your big data that comes from different
types of omics data so we aim to utilize
this beginner level to advanced level
Project based coursework and the case
studies that are published on the portal
that generally focuses on data science
techniques and programming languages and
machine learning methods so these
techniques and different programming
languages could be used to analyze these
different types of comics data and by
omics I am collectively speaking about
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics and also single cell
transcriptomics throughout my uh talk I
would be uh discussing a lot about this
on its term so I'm a bionics I am
referring to all of the studies
collected
So This research fellowship program
would include a high grade training
material that I just take you through
where we'll discuss about these
different Comics techniques now let's
say once we are well equipped with these
omics techniques there are various
resource specialization tracks in which
uh a research fellow a researcher or a
student can actually work in so we get
these questions by uh students from
different universities and degrees where
they asked where they could apply a
specific type of skill set in which to
research tract should they be working on
or which research field they should pick
to carry out a certain type of interest
that they have
so I want to discuss all of this today
and help you know about these different
resources that you can Leverage
so this is the omics logic learn portal
where SRI gauri had asked you to sign up
as you have a bunch of courses that you
get an access to as a part of the
research fellowship program which
includes different omics and data
science coursework and all of this is in
regards to biomedical data analysis I'm
doing so as a student or a researcher
who comes from a different background
let's say non-biarismatics background
entirely a microbiologist or a
biochemist or medical sciences and
you're interested to transition into
this field of bioinformatics we get
started uh with the very basics of
bioinformatics through a course that is
Introduction to bioinformatics
so right now I'm explaining the program
structure to you there are two uh two or
three rather types of program structures
that you can enroll yourself in into
either two months or for three months or
for six months based on uh the time you
have or I must say the dissertation
periodic university has asked you to
complete it or your research proposal if
you're a researcher working with a lab
all right so if you come from a
non-bioinformatics background you get
started with the course on introduction
to bioinformatics this course includes
Basics about what is bioinformatics what
is the role of big data and
bioinformatics what is the role of
bioinformatics and Healthcare and what
is translational bioinformatics
discussing the applications of the field
bioinformatics and various research
specialization tracks
now if I talk about what is inside these
lessons we have textual Concepts videos
are there images are there research
Publications are there to supplement
your knowledge with the same and towards
the end you have some quizzes and
assignments put together to access your
um knowledge that you gain from a
specific lesson
now when we discuss about different
omics fields and different resource
specialization track
you might be unaware of what these
different on experience are or what
these different specialization tracks
are that you could really work upon so
we have put together a course that uh
that is bytes and molecules that you can
go through if you are a beginner and you
want to learn about these different
types of comics Fields many of the
students who join us uh they have a
question that they want to do a project
in the pane of bioinformatics but
they're not sure which type of data
should they work with or which type of
field should they uh apply a specific
type of data analysis that they would
learn so for me students we take them
through this process where we uh teach
them about all the different types of
fields and introduction obviously and
based on their interest then we take
them a step ahead and take them through
a specialized training process now let's
say if a research internal joint also
the bites in the molecules coursework
and say that I am entrusted in
transcriptomic studies so the next step
for them would be to take up a
specialized training in transcriptomic
studies now what do I mean by a
specialized training if it's
transcriptomics for a student then it is
important for them to know what type of
sequencing techniques are there to
sequence transcriptomic data what type
of data format is generated from these
sequencing techniques how to analyze the
different types of data formats that
come up from these techniques what are
the algorithms that would be used for
other steps of pre-processing mapping
quantification and then carrying of the
downstream analysis for transfer
Plumbing data and in terms of algorithms
what do they do what type of parameters
they take what type of outputs they give
you and then how do you interpret them
so there is a flow from data generation
to biological interpretation so that
flow is taken up in this specific
coursework that a research fellow has to
then go through and get a good Hands-On
understanding with transcriptomic data
in all of these courses you will find an
example data set that we have taken up
with which we are working and for
practice you can take up the same data
set practice the pipelines and by
pipelines I am referencing to a platform
that is the team bioinfo platform so we
have two platforms for us those who are
new and are joining us for the first
time this is for them one is the
mixlogic non-potal where you learn all
of these different types of fields and
resource specialization tracks and then
you have the T bioinfo platform where
you actually carry out the Hands-On
analysis or practice these different
types of Pipelines
now there are two types of people who
um like to quote who want to learn how
to code and the ones who don't like to
code or they are just core biologists
interested in the insights of their
their results but do not have a good
Hands-On with coding languages so for
those type of people the best platform
is the tea by info platform and also if
you're you are a coding person you
definitely want to process your data
from past your files to get a gene
expression table at least
which requires a high Computing system
otherwise if you don't have the platform
so in that regards the platform has some
AI built machine learning tools already
put together and these pre-built tools
could be used to process your data
mapped uh the reads on the referenced in
um quantify the data carry out on stream
analysis do there are two different
types of uh
processes at different steps
I won't go much in depth of the platform
but right now because my aim today is to
discuss about the resources and the
program structure and also the research
specialization tracks okay so now when I
talk about these different pipelines how
to use them how what type of results do
you get everything is there in the
lessons itself in the course that you
take up now once your course is complete
the next step comes to uh summative
research proposal where you uh put
together what is your research interest
in which field you want to carry out
this research you have to explore
various public repositories to look for
a data set that you would like to work
on and submit that data set link as well
in The Proposal form throughout this
program in the beginning in your
training session you would be also
taught how to explore various public
repositories how to extract the data and
how to prepare it for further analysis
now when I talk about different research
specialization tracks I want to mention
here what are those tracks on which we
specifically work on the first one is
infectious diseases
we have put together this page on
Research specialization tracks and
topics I'll put the link in the chat box
on this page we have put together the
research specialization tracks and the
type of data analysis that is possible
and each one of these different
specialization tracks that you can work
on as a research fellow one is
infectious diseases and then you have
the list of different data analysis that
is possible under this field then you
have oncology and also on the page
itself you have some example projects or
case studies that we have worked upon
they're also mentioned on the onyslogic
learn portal I will be just taking up
these points very briefly here keeping
the time limit and uh you have the link
we'll share the link with you as well
you can take your time and explore these
different topics that you would like to
work on when you join the program
the second fiend is oncology that you
can work on with applications or with
the usage of different types of omics
data again and also a multi-ohms
integration is possible too and
structural bioentine automatics work
would be done as well
the next type of resource specialization
track you have is precision medicine and
under Precision medicine again different
types of data could be analyzed like
transcriptronic data clinical data
epigenomic data and genomic data the
next field is agriculture under
agriculture we have an example project
onto an on potato
thought resistance so those who are
interested and are curious to learn how
an agriculture based study could be done
using these different types of data uh
could go through the portal go through
this case study and you have these uh
research questions that we have put
together for them
the next screen is neurosciences and
then metabolic disorders and space omics
we have put together some research
questions for these different fields as
well that the researcher could work upon
and different types of analysis that is
possible so in total there are six
fields that I went through infectious
diseases oncology neurosciences
agriculture recession medicine metabolic
metabolic disorders and space omics now
if you are interested to work uh or take
up any one of these different resource
specialization tracks and are curious
what type of analysis could be carried
out you are free to go through this
entire page and if you have any
questions you can get back to us on our
email IDs or we also have a WhatsApp
group we can share the group link with
you and we can meet and discuss your
research in trust and get you started
with your journey of the research
research fellowship program
so that was it that I wanted to discuss
and now I would like to pass on pass on
the stage to Sri gauri over to you
srivani
thank you so much America let me share
my screen and
discuss about what are some of the um
research fellows then up to after the
completion of the program
so
you might be wondering what comes after
completing the courses and example
projects as a part of the program so the
answer is possibilities are ended so to
begin with uh majority of the students
are focused on publishing their work for
instance a biomedical fine graduate
student she focused on assessing the
underlying reason for the development of
gray matter nations in multiple specific
versus patients at their
transcriptometer and for though she went
on to publish her work in immunogenetics
and Open Access Journal that focuses on
the genetic research area autoimmune
disorders that have multiple experiences
rheumatoid arthritis
and another interesting student
publication is that of a genetic
engineering student he studied the
effect of malaria wax on the
transcription profile of patients to
determine to determine its efficacy and
understand the molecular mechanisms
underlying the protection that the
vaccine provides he also went on to
publish his work in genomics and
informatics which is the official
Journal of the Korea genome organization
presently like them we have several
other students who are working on their
publication just like nivedita a
biotechnology graduate student she's
working on transcriptomic study or
cancer treatment on patients and it
after effects leading to
and like how we are looking forward to
several other Publications from our
present students further you also have
the opportunity to participate in omics
research in Pokemon and post the
presentation of computation to win
exciting cash prizes and the Symposium
is an International Symposium that
brings together experts such as Dr
Gareth trouble staff scientist at
Lawrence Livermore National Laboratory
and Dr Joseph Borg associate professor
at University of Malta amongst so many
other experts who join as guest speakers
and notice and the student projects are
not just limited to graduates and
breadth and undergraduate for instance
Andre modernosa a high school student at
Mexico presented his Neuroscience
project at the regeneron international
science and engineering pair for which
he won the potamkin prize and the fourth
award in the biomedical and Health
Sciences category and this program can
also be integrated as the part of the
existing university university
curriculum for instance we collaborated
with the assistance medicine graduate
program at Georgetown University where
the lecturers were prepared considering
the interest of the program director to
address challenges relevant to clinical
application and biomedical research and
the training ended with students
submitting their research project on the
portal and the topics range from as
displayed in the screen from infectious
diseases metabolic disorders
Neuroscience psychiatric disorder
oncology machine learning and so on so
all of these projects have been carried
out on machine learning using Python
Programming and these projects can also
be showcased for higher studies and
International University application
like some of our research fellows like
the Lara ranking who got accepted to the
harassmented imbrc program in Marine
Biology Andrew mehra who got accepted to
the Precision medicine graduate program
in Manchester and Anusha who got access
accepted to the PHD program in
metagenomics at the University of Sweden
and faculties and researchers have also
collaborated to our programs to publish
their research work
and our latest collaboration has been
with a team of researchers at noguchi
Memorial Institute for medical research
at the University of Ghana They carried
out to understand a computational study
to understand the variants that we
created with calcium resistance and
plasmodium and it is also possible to
pursue an entrepreneurship and business
Innovation track like a team of Industry
researchers from biologic Support
Services a biotechnology company in
Nigeria their aim was to improve the
fertility of women in Nigeria and
improve their chances of carrying their
babies term by developing a test kit and
this entrepreneurship track is not only
pursued by researchers but also by
students for instance a group of
undergraduate and postgraduate students
from Vellore Institute of Technology
worked on developing an early detection
kit for the detection of neurological
disorders with 8th specific purpose and
Alzheimer's disease so these are some of
the research outcomes that I wanted to
showcase so now to get involved with the
program and to understand what are the
various registration options that we
have I would like to pass on the stage
to shubham Kumar who will be explaining
more on over to YouTube
thank you so much
and hello everyone I am shubham I'll be
like briefing you about the uh the
registration part for the bioinformatics
and research fellowship program
so shigori could confirm if my screen is
visible
it is yes now we can see the program
page
all right so as you all can see that
this is our uh like uh the program page
or you can say the landing page also so
here you will get to know about the uh
all the informations like what all
you'll be getting or why we have
designed this process so as you can see
the this program has been designed for
the uh to help the young researchers and
like students who are working on the
dissertation project or for the thesis
work so that they can take the advantage
of bioinformatics resources and work on
the complex data analysis part so what
we all will be providing is like you
will be getting get you will be getting
get trained along with that you will get
the mentorship from industry Academy
experts and apart from that as uh
sunalica mentioned you will getting you
will be getting the access of T by info
server which is a cloud-based platform
for a big data analysis
so as we scroll down you will find that
we have like us we can say three-step
process for our research Fellowship so
first you will be getting let's say uh
you are a beginner for the
bioinformatics field so as earlier
mentioned you will be like providing
with some of the trainings from omix
logic loan platform where you will be
going through the courses related to
your field of interest and uh while
going through the courses uh let's say
you come up with a research topic or a
research question to work on so that
will shift to your second step that is
we will be working on your research
topic as well as you will be working on
your literature review partner so that
you come up with the best research
question and uh proper data set to work
on your analysis part so in these steps
you will be working on the Second Step
you will be working on your data sets
and the analysis part and after it is
completed uh you will be like shifted to
the third part which is the present
presentation of analysis for the expert
feedback and the publication part
so as we will scroll down you can see
here that we have three different angles
or you can like uh four different Tenors
like two months three months or six
months so the common tenures which we
have uh for all these 10 news is uh you
will be like going through some of the
earth synchronous courses and apart from
that you'll be working on some of the
Hands-On assignments or Hands-On
projects also and group sessions will
also be there and let's say if you miss
some of the sessions then we will
provide you with the recordings also you
will be getting the Hands-On coding
sessions and apart from the Online
technical and Mentor support will always
be there and you will be also getting
the access of the uh or mix logic
program axis and educational Cloud
pipeline license for your T by info
server now the extra benefit what you
will be getting for the 60 days tenure
is like you will be uh like getting a
chance for the literature review part
and after that you can come up with the
proper research project report work and
as uh mentioned by SRI gauri uh you can
like showcase your research proposal in
a form of a poster at various
International symposiums
now coming for the 90 days part uh all
these uh like the outcomes you will be
getting for the 90 days is like
literature review then you will be
getting the one-on-one mentorship
guidance and after your project
completion you will be getting the
chance to uh for a publication part
so uh on this page when you will scroll
down like you can see uh like some of uh
the projects uh some of the projects by
our previous research fellows related to
the infectious diseases than in the
field of space omics they have performed
some of the project then in in the field
of precision oncology then machine
learning skin diseases and data driven
drug Discovery uh parties also there so
you can see the video or like the
presentation also now coming on how you
can enroll so uh
uh just a second the page is loading
foreign
and what all I have just explained you
so um
you can see uh all that thing we have
summarized in the program overview
section like what all the topics and
concepts of what all access you will be
getting and apart from that you you will
what all like resources will be getting
like training mentorship then Cloud
tools and project support and coming to
the pricing part uh as we can see uh
like for 45 days it is dollar 350 and
for 60 days it is dollar 450 and for 90
days it is dollar 550 and let's say for
Indian Community uh you can see Indian
narration Community you can see there's
a drop down here so just click on that
thing and uh you can like change your
denomination or a currency from wherever
you belonging to so for Indian Community
you can see the prices have changed and
they have already been discounted so for
45 days we have like eight triple nine
for 60 days we have 14 the nine and for
90 days we have 19 or 19 triple 9 and
for like 20 days also we have something
similar to this this also and let's say
for our like African Community uh they
can also view their price like say if
you're from Nigeria then you can see the
prices here in the Nigeria in naira
so how to get yourself enrolled so let's
say I'm interested for the 90 days part
you can see all the resources which I
have just mentioned you you simply have
to click on buy now
and
yeah you will be coming at this checkout
page and you can simply enter your user
details uh don't forget to click on this
check box and after that you can select
any of the method like stripe or PayPal
or also we have an alternative methods
for our Indian Community via UPI or bank
transfer and for other participants also
we have the alternative payment option
using pay then
so and this was all about the uh you can
say the registration part so if you have
any queries please feel free to ask
foreign
so we'll pause for a couple of seconds
for the participants to share their
queries we can either unmute yourself
and ask for please feel free to post it
in the chat and we'll be happy to answer
uh we have one query from Professor
Hussein he's asking can I get any
discount as fellow
uh yes professor and Dr Hussain like we
have several scholarships ranging from
20 to 50 percent uh as you can see here
on the screen I think it is still
visible yeah so we have some
scholarships ranging from 20 to 50
percent so you can mail us uh your
details for the scholarship part at
marketing at omics logic I'll just share
you the mail ID
you can mail us at this ID and we will
discuss with her team and provide you
with a suitable uh scholarship part
yeah thank you sugary uh she has already
given her details to contact us
so you can email us at marketing
omicslogic.com or you can also message
us at this particular number it is also
available on WhatsApp so both uh like
whichever part you think is feasible you
can messages
[Music]
thank you so much and we have also
shared the links to our social groups on
WhatsApp and uh telegram as well so
please feel free to join that group
where you can post your queries as well
and with that does England's have any
further queries about
joining the research fellowship program
or
about the program registration if so
we'll be happy to answer
okay it looks like no one has no further
queries if so we'll be ending today's
webinar
all right then thank you so much
everyone for joining today's webinar and
if you have any queries once again
please feel free to reach out to us
through the email ID and the contact
number that we have provided and with
that thank you so much everyone and we
look forward to seeing you at the
research fellowship program and have a
great day thank you